Speaker 1: I have for you today one of
the craziest political stories that I
have ever covered, and it might not seem that
crazy because it has been slowly building.
But former Vice President Mike Pence has now
turned on Donald Trump publicly in a speech at the
Federalist Society in Florida over the weekend.
And Donald Trump has reacted by completely
losing it on Mike Pence. It is not normal that
a former president and vice president just 13
months after leaving office are in such public
conflict. Mike Pence publicly now has said that
he had no ability or right to overturn
the results of the 2020 election,
and Trump doesn't like that because Trump wanted
Pence to steal the election. This is part of the
growing civil war in the Republican Party.
And let me tell you clearly and directly,
this is not normal. It is not normal for a
president and a vice president to have such major
public disagreements so quickly after leaving
office, and it is not over something minor.
This is something major, the president says he
won, and the vice president could have flipped
the results. The vice president says we didn't
win and I have no right to change the results.
This is a disagreement as big as anybody could
imagine dealing with the most fundamental and
crucial elements of how our democracy is supposed
to work. Let's go to the clip. Here is Mike Pence.
Speaker 2: President Trump said I had
the right to overturn the election,
but President Trump is wrong. I had no right to
overturn the election. The presidency belongs to
the American people and the American people alone.
And frankly, there is no ideal more un-American
than the notion that any one person
could choose the American president
under the Constitution. I had no right
to change the outcome of our election,
and Kamala Harris will have no right to overturn
the election when we beat them in 2024. All right.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, maybe, maybe. But
Pence is correct in what he is saying there,
and Donald Trump very quickly completely triggered
putting out a statement saying quote just saw Mike
Pence's statement on the fact that he had no right
to do anything with respect to the electoral vote
count other than being an automatic conveyor
belt for the Old Crow. Mitch McConnell to get
Biden elected president as quickly as possible.
That was one sentence. Well, the vice president's
position is not an automatic conveyor if obvious
signs of voter fraud or irregularities exist.
That's why the Democrats and rhinos
are working feverishly. Interesting.
I would describe this statement as febrile.
Interesting that Trump uses the word feverishly
working feverishly together to change the very law
that Mike Pence and his unwitting advisers used on
January six to say he had no choice. The reason
they want it changed is because they now say they
don't want the vice president to have the right to
ensure an honest vote. In other words, I was right
and everyone knows it. Now, of course, that's not
true. The truth about that is pre-Trump. There was
no disagreement as to the vice president's ability
to to flip an election because it even came up in
2020, and the former, the now former then almost
former president, was pushing Pence to do this.
There is a move to strengthen the language to
make it even more clear. But the vice president
does not have the opportunity or ability to
change election results. Trump lastly says if,
in other words, I was right and everyone knows it,
if there is fraud or large scale irregularities,
it would have been appropriate to send those
votes back to the legislatures to figure it out.
The Dems and RINOs want to take that right
away. A great opportunity lost, but not forever.
In the meantime, our country is going to hell.
Hi, folks, this is not normal. This this really
is kind of like an end of days type situation,
which hopefully just won't actually lead to the
end of days. That's that's that's the hope
that this is just OK. Yeah, this is crazy.
But he's out of power and he's not going to be
back in power. That's the optimistic scenario.
Now, it's very important to mention at this
point, it seems abundantly clear that if
Trump does run in 2024 and wins the nomination,
his running mate is not going to be Mike Pence.
I can only imagine who it would be that would.
An interesting choice, and I would assume
it would be someone even more radical than Pence.
Now I think there's an important disclaimer to
make here as far as Pence being the good guy.
This is too little, too late. It has been 13
months since the attempted insurrection. He was
just doing his job, and what I mean by that is
he can't overturn the election. It was crazy
that Trump even tried to get him to attempt it.
Pence caused a ton of damage during his reign
as vice president. He said almost nothing about
this until now. He doesn't get a medal. Pence is
horribly toxic. He couldn't overturn the election.
He didn't choose not to overturn it. He couldn't
overturn it. All he's saying now is it's true. I
couldn't overturn it. Imagine not killing someone
in January of 2021, after your friend urges you,
your friend, to please kill this person. You don't
do it. And then in February of twenty two, you go,
I was right. Not to kill anybody. Right? Murder
is illegal. You don't get a cookie for reminding
us that 13 months later, 13 months later, that 13
months ago you did the only thing you could do.
You couldn't overturn the election and you
didn't. You don't get a cookie for that.
Now what's the upside here? The upside
is what we're soon going to discuss,
which is that this rift between Pence and Trump
adds to the Republican fragmentation. Here's
an example here is former Trump propaganda
Stephen Bannon attacking Pence over this?
Speaker 2: Pence, you're going to you're going
to carry this thing eventually to your grave, OK,
because it is a mark of shame
and you are a stone cold coward,
a stone cold coward. Boris Epstein. We're
going to start with numbers and analysis.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Pence could have done nothing
else. The only thing the only thing Pence could do
was not try to overturn the election
because he does not have the right
or the power to overturn the election. It
was the law. It was the Constitution. But
it's furthering the rift within the Republican
Party. And I argue that that is a very good thing